our planet hasn't looked this healthy in
decades with fewer people on the road
our air and water has become cleaner and
clearer and the effects are visible from
space NASA's Earth Observatory has been
documenting our world for decades 20
years of photos show the changes in the
atmosphere land air and water from the
Himalayas
to South America nASA has launched a
competition for the public to vote on
the top photos to celebrate 20 years of
learning about our rounds around the Sun
as a way to commemorate Earth Day many
of these images were taken by astronauts
or satellites scientists say they are
important in understanding our world we
are going to a crisis also exacerbated
by the fact that we have this panda Mia
now threatening humankind and making us
feel really feel our fragility and then
we feel now not only offer agility but
the fragility of our environment
voters can choose from lunar eclipses
volcanic eruptions or water Wonderland's
the effects of climate change are also
among the top snapshots as an astronomer
I know the uniqueness of our environment
I know that there are billions and
billions of planets out there but like
the earth broadly not many paranormal
which makes our presence here now a
miracle so we have to preserve that the
competition is now down to these two
photos ocean sand bahamas from 2002 and
reich okay erupts from 2019 the winner
will be announced later this month these
images from space show us how 7 billion
people impact our planet and how it
continues to have an impact on us Lea
harding al jazeera
[Music]